in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
find the lateral area surface area and
volume of a pyramid and the first thing
we want to talk about here is the
formulas now the formula for lateral
area the lateral area means the area of
the sides which of course in a pyramid
the size are made up of triangles so we
can use this formula 1/2 perimeter of
the base times the slant height Alice
for like the leaning height of the slant
height that would be five in this
particular example but I just want to
show you where the formula comes from
real quick if you find the area of one
of the triangles which we know is
one-half base times height and we
multiply it by the number of triangles
let's just call that n n times B ok so B
represents the base of the triangle
times a number of triangles that would
actually end up being the perimeter so
that's why n times B we write SP that H
is the height of the triangle but in the
pyramid we call that L or the slant
height so that's where this formula is
coming from right here for the surface
area though we're going to take the
lateral area which is the sides and
we're going to add on the base so when
you see that capital B that's the area
of the base so whatever shape that is if
it's you know a hexagon you have to find
the area of a hexagon if it's a square
you know the find the area of a square
and then lastly the volume one-third of
the area of the base times the height
and what I try to demonstrate here is
that if you were to put a pyramid inside
of a prism if the bases are the same and
the height is the same you could
actually put three of these pyramids
inside of that prism okay so that means
that one of these is going to take up
one-third of the volume so let's go
ahead and work through this problem here
the lateral area is going to be one half
the perimeter of the base times the
slant height the perimeter is going to
be four times 8 which is 32 the slant
height is five you don't want to make
the mistake of using this what they call
lateral edge okay that's where the
lateral faces come together you want the
height of the triangle that's the slant
height so this comes out to 16 times 5
which is 80 units squared remember areas
square units now if we want to find the
surface area we just have to add on that
square on the bottom 8 times 8 is 64
that's the area of the base so if we add
on 64 we're gonna get a hundred
forty-four units squared and then for
the volume we're just gonna do one-third
the area of the base times the height
the area of the base is sixty-four times
the height oh we don't know the height
so how are we gonna find that height
well what you can do is you can make a
triangle like this so if this side
length is eight that means this must be
half it's four and then you can see that
this is a triangle here a right triangle
we can use the Pythagorean theorem or if
you recognize your Pythagorean triples
this is going to be a three four five
Pythagorean triple which makes that
height three of course you can use the
Pythagorean theorem as well one-third
times 3 is 1 times 64 is 64 so we get 64
units cubed for the volume now let's do
a more challenging one that involves
some trigonometry and let's do that one
next okay number two we have a
pentagonal pyramid because the base is a
five sided regular polygon and we want
to find out what exactly is the lateral
area surface area and volume see if you
can do this one on your own and if you
get it right let me know in the comments
below because I I definitely made this
one more challenging but the first thing
I would do here is I'd recognize that
they're giving us the overall height
which is H they're giving us the slant
height which is our L which is 13 and if
we do our Pythagorean theorem we can
find out what this length is right here
and that's going to be 5 it's a 5 12 13
Pythagorean triple now let's take a look
at this base let's see if we can draw it
a little bit bigger here off to the side
now this 5 right here see how it's the
perpendicular distance from the centre
of the Pentagon to the side that's our
apothem
so this is going to be 5 right here and
remember when you worked with regular
polygons meaning all the sides are
congruent all the angles are congruent
you can find this central angle by
taking 360 divided by 5 which is 72
degrees when we drop the altitude it's
going to bisect that central angle
that's going to be 36 degrees now we can
find out what the length of this side is
okay so let's see what is that going to
be let's just call this X so we've got
opposite and adjacent that's tangent so
we have the tangent of 36 degrees
opposite over adjacent if we multiply
both sides by five you can see that x
equals five times the tangent of 36 and
let me see what that is on the
calculator I'm gonna round a little bit
here so it's about three point six three
now if I double that to get the length
of the side that comes out to about
seven point two seven just rounding here
and if we want to find the perimeter we
would take that seven point three seven
and multiply by five so that's about
thirty six point three three okay for
the perimeter but now what we want to do
is we want to find the lateral area okay
of this pyramid so lateral area is equal
to one half the perimeter which is
thirty six point three three times the
slant height which is the L the leaning
height here which is thirteen so let's
multiply that out times thirteen times
1/2 so we're looking at a lateral area
of two hundred thirty six point one
three units squared if we want to find
the surface area which is the total area
so we have to add on that base we're
gonna take the lateral area which we
just found plus the area of this
Pentagon what's the formula for area of
a Pentagon
well regular polygon we use the formula
one-half apothem times perimeter the
apothem we said was five
that's this perpendicular distance from
the center to the side and the perimeter
is going to be seven point two seven
times five which we said was thirty-six
point three three so let's see if we can
multiply that out thirty-six point three
three times 0.5 times five and then
that's about ninety point eight three
and we're gonna add it to the two
hundred thirty six point one three so
this is about okay I'm rounding here so
it's about three hundred twenty six
point nine six units squared that's for
our surface area now for the volume we
have to use our form the one-third area
of the base times the height well we
found the base which was the ninety
point eight three so it's going to be
one-third times ninety point eight three
times the height now you want to make
sure you use the overall height
the volume not the slant height so this
height is going to be 12 and 1/3 times
12 is 4 times the 90.8 3 so it looks
like it's about three hundred and sixty
three point three two units cubed for
volume and you got it if you want to see
more examples with like cylinders and
prisms and spheres and all different
shapes using lateral area surface area
and volume follow me over to that more
comprehensive video where we go through
all these different polyhedrons their
areas volumes shapes etc and how the
formulas relate to one another to help
you memorize them more easily so I'll
see you in that video right there